hey ready alright alright secret sign
hey Ryan
very good excellent excellent Michael
today at lunchtime we are going to be
playing the warehouse staff and a
friendly little game of basketball my
idea the last time I was down there I
noticed they put up a couple of Hoops
and I play basketball every weekend so I
thought this might be kind of fun and so
I start messing around and I'm sinking a
few you know swish swish swish
nothing but net and their jaws just drop
to the floor
African Americans oh you know it's
really just a good friendly game reason
for everybody to get together are we
ready for the game I know grumble
grumble but you would follow me to the
ends of the earth grumbling all the way
like that dwarf from Lord of the Rings
Gimli nerd that is why you're not on the
team just trying to be helpful
yeah I'll have elven Dragonslayer is ten
point tyrants word okay so let's put
together starting lineup shall we
Stanley of course I'm sorry um what do
you play Center why of course what's
that supposed to mean
I don't know I I don't remember her
saying that I heard it well people hear
a lot of things man um other starters me
of course I heard at that time I'd like
to play if it's just for fun I played
basketball in school yeah who else
we have gym we have Ryan the new guy
right untested willing to prove himself
right now a lot of passion a lot of
heart but I'm getting paid to skip lunch
right yes yes this is business
yeah the business of team building and
morale boosting oh who else I can help
out if you need me I will use your
talents come baseball season my friend
or if we box I have a hoop in my
driveway no I have a sports bra no no
ridiculous
Michael look
close all right ah me stand the man Jim
Ryan and Dwight yes sorry Phyllis can I
be team captain no I'm team captain can
I be team manager no I am a team manager
you can be assistant to the team an
assistant team manager oh okay well see
was working this weekend Jim you're in
charge of the vacation schedule now oh
yeah
threat neutralized okay listen this is
just going to be a friendly game right
we are all on the same team here
dunder mifflin team of course if you
beat us
you're fired that's a joke okay let's do
it
game yeah all right stretch it pull
stretch
Ryan your stretch let's stretch before I
can't okay okay Ryan you have Darryl I
have Roy really I thought it dick boy no
actually boys our best player not lying
so Dwight you have the East German go
okay all right you guys okay we'll be
skin white what should I honor off on
just put it on you sure yes Pam you kind
of have your foot in both camps here why
don't you do the jump ball okay don't
listen to him Pam trust me
tip it my way or sleep in the car
what you gotta be kidding me
you